you so it joins me now from Port Sudan
so what's the latest situation they used
for how's it looking there
I mean people here are still scrambling
to evacuate some have been given the
opportunities some haven't there is a
lot of organizing on a community level
people giving out food and supplies but
they're very limited those really no
humanitarian response presence on the
ground we haven't seen the United
Nations on the ground we haven't seen
any other of the international
ngos that operate in Sudan actually
giving people shelter the shelter that
we saw at the Port yesterday protecting
people from scorching Sun you know 40
degree heat was actually a community
initiative so people here do feel
abandoned this is a feeling that they've
had for a while as you and led mediation
failed between the two generals that we
have seen now destroy the capital those
that do get to leave seem to be those
that have foreign passports some of them
have been collecting in certain areas
and there are still lots of foreign
Nationals that haven't been able to get
on about on a ship that haven't been
able to get on a plane and instead have
gotten on a bus to the border to Egypt
so there have been people that have been
left behind by embassies and and
governments of foreign countries that we
actually yes last night were taken to a
building that had been booked entirely
by the United Nations incredibly
beautiful building and people here are
asking why is the United Nations not
offering temporary shelter at the very
least for the people that have fled this
conflict the numbers now are looking at
at least 75 000 people displaced so far
and the conflict is still ongoing every
ceasefire that we have heard be
announced has only partially held in the
capital fighting has still continued
Hospital are shutting down a msf
supported hospital was actually attacked
and destroyed and there are many other
situations like this so the question is
when will the International Community
respond in any sort of way I'm not
saying adequately I'm not saying I'm on
a massacre I'm saying just respond
um two people here the evacuations have
been led by countries uh eager to get
their citizens out and even that even
then the Brits the British government
has been criticized for its delayed
response but we are yet to see an
adequate response on the ground that is
supporting people through this crisis
you sir thanks very much indeed